-There's a pretty embarrassing
scene in the film
where Charlize's character
is blackmailed
because of a video
that you are in.
-Yes. In the film, they hack
into my little webcam.
And, you know, I'm kind of
in a romantic relationship
with a woman
running for president.
So a big media conglomerate
hacks into my webcam
and catches me doing what they
would actually catch me doing
if they hacked into my webcam,
which is disgusting things,
all the time.
[ Laughter ]
And, so, yeah,
there's a scene where --
I don't know how to say it
elegantly.
So I'll just say it
and let you guys deal with it.
I [bleep] on my own face.
And so I --
-That was elegant.
You're being hard on yourself.
That was elegant.
-Not on purpose. It's not like
a thing my character does.
It's not like the windbreakers.
It was not as strong.
It's an accident
in the context of the film.
But they capture it
on the webcam.
And what's funny is, to film it,
I literally shot it
on my own computer
alone in a hotel room
because it was like --
And it wasn't real, but I did
have, like, an apparatus
to squirt myself in the face.
And it is one of those moments
where I'm like,
"What I'm pretending to do
and what I'm doing
are like a hair's breadth away
from being as gross
as one another."
Like, this is disgusting to do
but works very well comedically
in the context of the film.
And I encourage you all
to go see "Long Shot."
[ Laughter ]
-I am very excited.
I was backstage. And we've
talked about your mom before.
-Good segue.
"Speaking of [bleep]
on your own face,
your mother's backstage."
-I mean, it's not any mother.
I mean, it's Seth Rogen's
mother, so, yeah.
-She's fine with it, yeah.
-But we've talked about her
on social media.
And I got to meet her backstage.
And it was lovely to meet her.
-She is a lovely woman.
-And we also talked about
how you and Billy Eichner,
the last time you were here,
are going to be voices
in "The Lion King."
-Yes. We are Timon and Pumbaa.
-We didn't talk about that
you did "Billy on the Street."
And you did a bit where
you basically went around --
What was the bit you were doing?
-It was one of honestly the most
messed-up things I've ever done.
And it actually
emotionally messed me up
for around three weeks.
-Yeah.
-He went around New York,
and I was the cameraman
but kind of in disguise.
And he was telling New Yorkers
that I was dead.
[ Audience ohhs ]
And I was filming it.
And then they would react,
and at the end, he'd go,
"He's not dead.
He's right here filming it."
90% of people
did not give a [bleep].
[ Laughter ]
And the other 10% were
kind of psyched about it.
Genuinely, their first reaction
was like, "Fine."
And, yeah, my mom
did not care for it.
-Do you want to read --
Somebody tweeted --
And then do you want to read
your mom's reaction to it?
-My mom tweeted
to Billy Eichner.
"I want to hurt you for making
a video about Seth death,
even if it was funny.
You are a bum."
[ Laughter ]
She's like Rocky's corner man.
"Ya bum!"
Even she had to admit
it was funny, though.
-Yeah, she did admit
it was funny.
Thank you for
being here as always.
It is just such a delight
to have you, Seth.
-Thank you for having me.
-That is Seth Rogen.